six years after the original zombie
outbreak comes Resident Evil 4 Rezac
evil for the story picks up with Leon
Kennedy now working for the US Strategic
Command on his way to a remote Spanish
village in Europe to rescue Ashley the
daughter of the President of the USA Z I
feel there should be some sort of Donald
Trump joke here but I must resist
I must resist Ashley has been kidnapped
by a mysterious cult known as lost
sinner in our dots which translates to
the enlightened ones Leon is injected
with a mind controlling parasite known
as las Plagas I'm sure you don't need me
to translate that one before the
parasite has chance to control Leon he
and fellow captive Luis Serra escape and
work together to find Ashley and find a
las Plagas sample Ashley is found and
freed and the game becomes a little bit
of an escort mission
Ashley regularly hiding or being
kidnapped help the big bad guy of the
game is exposed as Osmond Sadler the
leader has lost Illuminatus who reveals
his plot to infect the president of the
USA using Ashley Leon takes out his
right-hand man chief Mendez in a
multi-stage fight in a burning ban and
then decides tick shelter in a castle
wrong move Leon because this is the home
of Ramon Salazar another one of Sadler's
cronies I've been expecting you
ashley is kidnapped again boom but louis
returns with pills to suppress Leon's
infection yay but sadly no happy ending
for Louise who is instantly killed by
Salazar Leung continues to search for
Ashley and then the moment we've all
been waiting for finally happens ada
wong is back a bit of advice
try using knives next time works better
for close encounters the femme fatale is
here to obtain a sample of las Plagas
for Albert Wesker no less yep
Wesker may be behind the scenes on this
one but he's certainly still pulling the
strings
Jack Kraus have one of Leon's pals who
died two years earlier suddenly appears
and is yet another operative working for
Wesker the to indulge in a knife fight
but ADA sees Leon in peril for stops
Krauser
if it isn't a [ __ ] in the red dress at
this point the pills that Leon is taking
to subdue las Plagas and not working too
well what ada once again refuses to
stand for that kind of behavior Leon and
Krauss have finally duel to the death
and of course our Leon is victorious he
then locates Ashley and uses some sort
of radio therapy device to remove the
pluggers parasites from their bodies
finally Leon with the help of Ada and a
well-placed rocket launcher defeat Lord
Sadler recovering the final las Plagas
sample
a detects it and valves that Wesco will
not receive it sorry Leon
the island is moments away from
destruction so Ashley on Leon jump on a
jetski and get that back size out of
there we did it
Resident Evil 4 in three minutes
hopefully you enjoyed that and if you
did you might even press that like
button Cheers
I'm open for blister chin grenades I'll
see you next time
[Music]